only on CBS this morning we're hearing
from two of the women who signed an open
letter revealing sexual harassment in
the national security community more
than 200 women signed the letter
claiming they survived sexual misconduct
or knew someone who had the letter says
many women are held back or driven from
this field by men who used their power
to assault at one end of the spectrum
and perpetuate sometimes unconsciously
environments that silence demean
belittle or neglect women at the other
Margaret Brennan is at the State
Department with their fight for change
Margaret good morning good morning
223 national security professionals
issued an urgent call for action
they've all been trained to help protect
Americans and in this letter they're
asking America to protect them if folks
haven't been directly affected they know
somebody who has and that whisperer
network has become more than a whisper
it's become a roar what do you think was
the trigger you know I think you know
part of this is this National moment all
of these women shouldn't have to put on
armor to be with their co-workers jenna
ben yehuda a former Intel analyst and
State Department official said the
recent wave of high-profile sexual
harassment cases sparked a conversation
among her fellow national security
professionals it took so little effort
to get so many women two hundred and
twenty three women each of those
officials including nearly 70 current
and former u.s. ambassadors as well as
individuals from the CIA Pentagon and
White House signed their name urging
action the letter entitled hashtag me to
net sack was co-authored by ben yehuda
who wrote quote we too are survivors of
sexual harassment assault and abuse or
know others who are it's everywhere how
will you protect empower and defend the
women who serve our nation
ambassador Gina Abercrombie Winn Stanley
said she grappled with multiple sexual
harassment experiences I didn't tell
people at work because it was just one
of those things that you had to deal
with she
said that despite rising the high ranks
over her 32 year career that still did
not protect her from unwanted advances
from a congressman during a meeting in
the late 1990s someone trying to kiss me
so I mean it was clear that it was not
of course a part of the policy
discussion and I said very kind of you
know thank you
again I'm of a generation where my
mother raised me to understand
this was part of the cost of being in a
male-dominated profession but the
Ambassador told us she does not want the
next generation to have their work
suffer from having to manage around the
misbehavior of male co-workers why
aren't we defending the women who took
the oath it's time ben yehuda and other
professionals shared concerns that even
when harassment or sexual assault is
reported through official channels no
immediate action is taken she recalled
sitting in morning meetings listening to
her co-workers demean women I was
frequently the fly-on-the-wall as some
very senior men sat around a table and
talked about who they thought was most
attractive the letter says existing
policies meant to prevent harassment are
often weak under enforced and can favour
perpetrators as they're tired of not
being listened to or heard so to all of
those women we say we hear you and we
are listening and we're calling on
people to make it stop when contacted by
CBS News the State Department says it
has determined that additional resources
are necessary to make sure allegations
aren't investigated the White House the
Pentagon and homeland security said
they're reviewing their existing
policies and the Office of the Director
of National Intelligence said that if
they do find there are silos we're
reporting is discouraged or retaliation
happens they will focus gaile all right
once again the conversation is
continuing and that is a good thing
thank you very much Margaret Brennan